the number of reported coronavirus cases
in Louisiana is now skyrocketing
Omar Villafranca is in New Orleans at
the center of the state's outbreak Omar
what are officials there doing to stop
this virus spread good morning they shut
down Bourbon Street to cut back on the
crowds I mean take a look around me it
is empty one city council member is
comparing what happened here to what
happened in the aftermath of Hurricane
Katrina but keep in mind the French
Quarter State opened during Katrina and
now Governor John bel Edwards just wants
people to stay home we have to start
flattening the curve
Louisiana Governor John bel Edwards
sounded the alarm Wednesday as the surge
in corona virus cases threatens to
overwhelm state resources the problem
isn't just that the cases are growing
everyday it is that they're growing
rapidly every day officials estimate New
Orleans could run out of ventilators by
the first week of April
while hospitals are already racing to
find more personal protective equipment
we have never dealt with this number of
sick people dr. Rebecca key is the
former Louisiana state health secretary
what is it like right now for the
medical staff at hospitals there have
been told to conserve so for example
wear your mask during the day but if
it's not wet or soiled put it in a paper
bag and save it for tomorrow that is
unprecedented doctors and elected
officials believe the city's annual
Mardi Gras celebration help accelerate
the viruses spread
that's where Terra Reis believes her
husband Lewis was likely infected with
Koba 19 we were out on the streets with
hundreds and thousands of different
people two weeks later Lewis who is
undergoing chemotherapy for colon cancer
had a fever he later tested positive and
on Saturday was admitted to the
emergency room the doctor called me and
told me miss Reece we're gonna have to
put your husband and ICU and we are
gonna put him on a ventilator just
thinking about my husband being at the
hospital just all by himself Tara says
she was prepared for the worst but on
Monday she received a text from Lewis
himself who is currently on
the mend is like a miracle because he
really was really really sick supplies
are beginning to flow into the state the
governor is expecting a shipment of 300
ventilators but even with that shipment
he expects to be short about 600
ventilators just in the New Orleans area
Anthony Omar thank you